dude when we filmed
uh the jackass movie the first movie
that you know um the scene where where
we were in the hummer going through the
desert and they're [ __ ] tattooing the
the off-road tattoo yeah it was henry
rollins in the movie yeah
but it was supposed to be mickey
supposed to be nikki sixx
and and i mean like they told me it was
gonna be nicky six
right and so i show up for that shoot
we're in the desert wherever we're gonna
film this [ __ ] thing right
and i'm sitting there just like every
other day on that goddamn movie just do
and [ __ ] blow except
on this day i've got my framed picture
of me as a little kid with nikki six and
i'm just [ __ ] working the lines off
of it
like as if as if nikki's going to be
really impressed by that
dude was totally sober already at that
point
like yeah cool [ __ ] kook
but uh then uh but then they were like
oh there's your hero nikki six [ __ ]
and and they went up to they sent me to
the bit and then rollins got out and i
thought
that ron's gonna beat me up because oh
dude yeah
because yeah he's very well and on top
of that
i i've been uh hooking up with this
chick
that always flew out to be with rollins
and like so she told me about like all
these like crazy rolling stories you
know and then i'm on howard stern's been
talking
i brought the chick on howard stern and
was like bringing up rollins
you know like so like in that room that
had already all happened
at the point when like they go go up to
the suv and roll it's gonna
try that the bit was that rollins was
gonna beat me up in the movie
you know oh my god yeah he was just
super cool
yeah did he even mention like he did
okay
nothing professional and then when my
book came out
uh and my book came out the the writer
like did an interview with rollins and
rollins said that he just didn't even
[ __ ] hadn't even ever heard about it
you know
good answer dude yeah
yeah dude